europe strategy for improving lives the
economy and the environment in the
Baltic Sea region is up for discussion
at the European General Affairs Council
on November 19 the strategies at
cornerstone of the Lithuanian presidency
has been a model of EU regional
interaction since 2009 it aims to boost
cooperation between the eight EU
countries around the sea and the more
than 85 million people who live there
the strategy tackles environmental
problems economic disparities between
richer nations like Sweden and Germany
and neighbors like Latvia or Poland and
social challenges part of it addresses
ways to save the sea from pollution for
example some 50,000 tons of chemical
munitions have been dumped in the Baltic
since World War two improving transport
links for greater trade and prosperity
is another focus the region's current
road and rail networks are incomplete
and need upgrading one project the rail
baltika system will link helsinki
through the Baltic States and via Warsaw
to Berlin providing for rail travel and
freight deliveries to the rest of Europe
the strategy also aims to boost
economies through new technologies like
this project in Vilnius where students
are building innovative means of
transport for moving around in a
sustainable way at the talks in brussels
the ministers will take stock of the
strategy and how the challenges of
limited resources and financing are
being addressed